Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard und guten
Morgen Markus wie geht's dir auch mir
geht's ganz gut neue originelle
Einstiegsfrage habe ich überlegt
unglaublich originell
aber ich bin erstaunt wie du drauf
gekommen bist
wahrscheinlich damals beim italienischen
Militär genau ich habe gestern an dich
gedacht vorgestern an dich gedacht und
das hat der Rhein fachliche Gründe ich
habe gelesen über China und will wissen
hast du schon deine China Sendung
aufgezeichnet ja mit frankieren und eine
sehr schöne Sendung geworden wird am 12
Februar ausgegangen
ja ja super super also man lernt die
Welt mit anderen Augen zu sehen genau
und man könnte als Kind Essenz sagen ähm
wir sollten unsere Perspektive auf die
Welt nicht für die einzige Perspektive
auf die Welt halten so und darüber finde
ich sollten wir heute mal sprechen ich
hätte baust mir gerade eine perfekte
Brücke ohne dass wir das abgesprochen
hätten da wo es ist ja gerade
Weltwirtschaftsgipfel und so weiter und
ich weiß gar nicht ich habe gar nicht
hingeguckt ob die Zahl der der
Privatjets der klimaretta diesmal noch
beeindruckender ist als beim letzten Mal
aber das ist ja schon immer sehr und das
hat nicht nur was mit der Höhenlage von
Davos zu tun knapp 1600 Meter das wirkt
alles immer sehr abgehoben und elitär
und wer mir wer mir wieder aufgefallen
ist und jetzt zum zweiten Mal wirklich
unangenehm aufgefallen ist ist Antonia
guteres der un-general du weißt der hat
in Sharm el Shake ja gesprochen dass wir
auf dem direkten Weg auf der Autobahn in
die Klima Hölle sein ja diesmal spricht
er von einem bedauernswerten Zustand in
dem die Welt sei die Herausforderungen
turmten sich ich zitiere wie Autos bei
einer Massenkarambolage also mit
Autobahnen und Auto Metaphern hat er es
irgendwie
und ich erfand das ist einfach das
Gefühl es ist nur noch Krise und das
originellste dazu habe ich gelesen ich
glaube bei den Kollegen der Welt die
hatten wunderbares Interview mit Neil
Fergus und das ist mein mein
bevorzugter Wirtschaftshistoriker
Schotte einer der sich immer traut
unbequeme Dinge zu sagen und der sagte
ist dir die Sache ist ganz einfach
Europa ist einfach ein elendes Museum
und wer jung ist ja und eine gute Idee
hat macht sich bis heute einfach auf den
Weg nach Kalifornien weil hier kann man
einfach nichts mehr reißen und ich
dachte oh wow das ist mein brutaler
Befunde
ja also es gibt natürlich Anlässe zur
sorgen es gibt doch Anlässe zu großen
Sorgen ohne jeden Zweifel aber der
Pessimismus in der Mentalität der hat ja
nicht nur was mit objektiven
Gegebenheiten zu tun ja der hat auch mit
Einstellungen und mit Haltung zu tun
wirklich genau das
wir empfinden uns irgendwie als das alte
Europa also das merkwürdigerweise ich
habe so das Gefühl je älter ich werde
umso mehr erreiche ich ungefähr das
Alter dass die durchschnittliche
deutsche Mentalität ausmacht so von der
Zukunft nicht mehr zu viel Gutes
erwartet ja also
so langsam sozusagen auf das gefühlte
altersniveau dieses Landes das irgendwo
zwischen 60 und 70 Licht glaube ich ne
also so fühlt sich dieses Land auch
junge Leute auf oft ja diese diese
dieser wir sind wir haben ja neulich
darüber gesprochen Weltmeister in in
Moralismus aber irgendwie sind wir ja
jetzt auch Weltmeister in Apokalypsen ja
nun sind wir ja nicht die einzigen also
die teres ist ja kein Deutscher und
trifft sich ja jetzt das ganze alte
Europa und das irgendwie auch alte
Amerika und natürlich treffen sich da
auch ein paar andere aber der der
Hauptschwerpunkt in Davos liegt
natürlich bei den alten ne den
etablierten erfolgreich Menschen und so
und die sagen sich so wie das jetzt die
letzten Jahrzehnte gingen mit
Globalisierung und Wirtschaftswachstum
und tollen Aktienkursen und so wird das
vermutlich jetzt nicht mehr weitergehen
ja das ist das eine darüber reden wir
gleich aber ich will trotzdem noch mal
einfach weil es wichtig ist und ich
verstehe nicht Richard warum wir uns
solche Geschichten nicht häufiger
erzählen ich meine die Wahrheit ist doch
trotz aller Apokalypse und trotz deines
gefühlten Alters das mittlerweile zu
Mentalität dieses Landes passt ja die
Wahrheit ist doch wer vor hundert Jahren
korrekt vorhergesagt hätte und das jetzt
in den 2020er Jahren Menschen doppelt so
lange leben wie damals den hätte man
ausgelacht wenn jemand gesagt du meinst
jetzt global ne ja wenn jemand gesagt
hätte die Erfindung von Antibiotika von
Digital Technologie auch die
landwirtschaftliche Revolution letzten
Endes das hatte niemand wirklich auf der
Liste das Leben war kurz viele Kinder
sind gestorben Krankheiten waren häufig
tödlich und so weiter selbst wenn du
darüber redest und auch darüber wurde in
eindringlichen Worten und wird ja immer
wieder gewarnt Stichwort Klimawandel im
August 2019 erinnert mich gab es einen
einen Bericht von von 100 oder ein paar
mehr noch Experten die darüber
gesprochen haben dass ich das
Zeitfenster unglaublich schnell schließt
dass uns bleibt um fruchtbaren Boden zum
Beispiel zu erhalten und die sagten es
geht mittlerweile zwischen 100 und 100
mal also zwischen 10 und 100 mal
schneller fruchtbarer Boden verloren als
er sich bildet das klingt nach
Apokalypse weil es bedeutet Bauern
werden nicht mehr in der Lage sein
Lebensmittel anzubauen und acht
Milliarden Menschen zu ernähren aber die
Wahrheit ist und das erzählen wir uns
auch viel zu wenig Hungersnöte sind Gott
sei Dank seltener geworden ich habe in
letzter Zeit ist wieder ein bisschen
mehr geworden
genau Tendenz der letzten Jahrzehnte war
ich weiß die Linken wollen das immer
nicht hören und ich zu haben und so
weiter ist relativ zur Weltbevölkerung
hungern und sterben an Hunger heute viel
weniger Menschen als in allen
Jahrzehnten früher ja das heißt also
diese Zahl der Menschen sinkt in letzter
Zeit ist da gerät dieser Motor ins
Stottern aber das über sehr sehr lange
Zeit so gewesen das ist sehr
beeindruckend finde ich aber wenn man
das sagt dann wird man immer wie jemand
dargestellt der diese unglaublichen
700 Millionen oder wie viele sind ein
Menschen die hungern oder vom Hunger tot
bedroht sind der das klein redet das tut
man natürlich nicht genau also das ist
mein Punkt zwei Dinge unterscheiden
einmal das riesige Elend in der Welt und
andererseits die Behauptung dieses Event
werde größer und das ist einfach nicht
der Fall ist das ist Elend wird relativ
gesehen zu der großen Zahl an Menschen
die immer weiter wächst wird das genau
er tendenziell kleiner als größer Axel
Bojanowski nicht sehr gerne lese und den
ich sehr schätze werden
liebe Grüße an der Stelle der hat weist
immer wieder auf solche Zusammenhänge
auch hin und habe neulich mal
aufgeschrieben dass mittlerweile die
Bewohner der ärmsten Länder pro Kopf
über so viel Kalorien verfügen wie in
den 1960er Jahren die Menschen bei uns
ja und in den vergangenen 30 Jahren hat
sich der Anteil armer Menschen von mehr
als einem Drittel auf unter zehn Prozent
in welchem Land ja so china hat seit
Beginn der eröffnungspolitik Ende der
70er Jahre und jetzt können wir die Zahl
an China hatte damals glaube ich 1,1
Milliarden Einwohner heute 1,4
Milliarden ja und davon haben damals 800
000 Menschen unter der Armutsgrenze
gelebt die Häuser über der Armutsgrenze
leben das hat am meisten überhaupt diese
Statistik verändert man müsste nämlich
noch mal genau hingucken und sagen okay
Hunger in der Welt zurückgeht er geht
natürlich natürlich nicht an einen
Stellen in der Welt parallel oder im
gleichen Ausmaß zurück sondern sozusagen
die die absolute positivbilanz ja ist
das was in China passiert ist ja und
aber das ist doch eine Erfolgsgeschichte
und die kann man doch auch mal erzählen
und die kann man doch auch mal nach
vorne tragen und gleichzeitig haben wir
die Tendenz und das ist ja auch
interessant wir haben so eine Tendenz
dann andere Krisen ja die die sozusagen
so aus unserem Blickfeld gerad über die
reden wir in wie gar nicht die finden
sozusagen einfach gar nicht statt die
sind weit weg ja also es ist natürlich
der Blickwinkel ist immer Krisen in
Deutschland werden am Ernstes genommen
in Europa am zweiten ernst ist und alles
andere ist das andere ich begründe das
immer so mit methusalemix ja im Geschenk
Caesars sagt mit USA nichts gegen Fremde
einige meiner besten Freunde sind Fremde
aber diese fremden hier die sind nicht
von hier
und so machen wir das auch ja also es
gibt deutsche es gibt fremde also
Europäer ja das sind sozusagen Freunde
die Fremde sind ja und dann gibt es die
Fremden die nicht von hier sind das sind
die Zustände in Angola und die Niger und
im Mali ja wo also im Augenblick
irrsinnige Dürrekatastrophen wüten
überhaupt nicht berichten ja also das
das finde ich ist so diese diese diese
perspektivverschiebung die wir uns viel
viel öfter ehrlich gesagt leisten
sollten und es ist so eine irgendwie so
eine intellektuelle Faulheit dass wir
uns immer wieder auf die gleichen Dinge
fokussieren lass uns das einmal kurz
besprechen Richard Angola nee
schlimmste Dürre seit 40 Jahren 3,8
Millionen Menschen das ein Zehntel der
Bevölkerung dort hat offenbar nicht
genug zu essen hunderttausende Kinder
unterernährt und dann hast du
Preissteigerungen bei Nahrungsmitteln
Getreide Speiseöl und so weiter
ausgelöst und da siehst du das alles mit
einem zusammenhängt durch den Krieg in
der Ukraine also das ist ein riesiges
Problem ja viele Familien die flüchten
die dann nach Namibia ins Nachbarland
flüchten und so weiter aber darüber
reden wir nicht nee wir hatten also wir
haben darüber geredet dass infolge des
ukrainekrieges in Afrika
Hungerkatastrophen drohen dann liefen
irgendwann nach dem getreideabkommen die
ersten getreideschiffe aus und davon
sind viele nicht nach Afrika Gefahren
viele sind auch woanders hingefahren
aber dann waren wir wieder beruhigt ja
und jetzt mal ganz genau hingucken ja
inwiefern also die die mangelnden
getreideausfuhren und der Mangel der
Dünger und so weiter die aus der Ukraine
kommen nun tatsächlich zu diesen Hunger
Katastrophen führen da gucken wir nicht
so genau hin das wollen wir lieber nicht
wissen weißt du eigentlich
das schon interessant ne also zum Thema
Getreide dieser Tage auch wieder Weizen
für die ernsthamsten und auch bei uns in
der Sendung wird dann ständig in in
Bedeutung schweren Worten davor gewarnt
wie Afrika darunter leidet und so weiter
was auch alles richtig ist und Annalena
baerburg mahnt dann das in afrikanischen
Ländern und im Nahen Osten dieses
Getreide dringend gebraucht wird aber
wusstest du dass die Mehrzahl der
Frachter die mittlerweile wieder liefern
also sowohl aus Russland als auch aus
der Ukraine dass die keineswegs Kurs auf
die Länder nehmen über die wir ständig
sprechen
[Musik]
Getreide ist ich hoffe dass ihr das sind
es ist Spanien okay und weißt du warum
der Großteil wird von Weizen meist
Gerste als Futtermittel in der Viehzucht
genau damit wir Schinken haben so viel
nur sozusagen zu dem was einerseits
Erkenntnis ist und was wir dann umsetzen
in konkretes Handeln das ist der
Solidarität ne wenn es wirklich ernst
wird dann ist Schluss damit beim
Schinken hört der Spaß auf genauso
sieht's aus
das andere ich hat also wenn du auf
Davos guckst und weil du gerade auch
über diese Gefühlslage sprichst und
sagst immer du nährst dich immer mehr
der Mentalität dieses Landes
weißt du wer mir in dem Zusammenhang
viel mehr Sorgen macht das ist genau das
andere Ende dieser dieser Alarmismus
speziell auch zum beim beim Thema Klima
und ich sag deutlich dazu ich will in
keinster Weise negieren das wären
ernsthaftes Thema haben als Menschheit
aber wo ist dann für dich der
allermeismus was was was was magst du
gar nicht an der Klima Diskussion ich
mag nicht wie wir zum Teil darüber reden
ich mag nicht wenn wir anfangen darüber
zu reden und zu sagen in zehn Jahren ist
das Fenster das uns noch bleibt zu wenn
ihn eindringlichen Worten davor gewarnt
wird dass wir jetzt in zehn Jahren kommt
der 15 Jahren kommt der Zeitpunkt wo wir
wieder sagen in zehn Jahren ist das wenn
es dazu
ja und das machen wir schon seit 30
Jahren dass wir das sagen das ist das
ist genau der Punkt das ist mein Thema
es gibt eine schöne Geschichte dazu
Richard und zwar einen Artikel an
ap-artikel associate press
Überschrift un prognostiziert
Katastrophe wenn Klimawandel nicht unter
Kontrolle Geräte einer von vielen
Artikeln die in der Zeit erschienen sind
klingt nach Weltuntergang da wird ein
ranghoher umweltbeamter der UN zitiert
der davon spricht dass ein
Meeresspiegelanstieg kann sie Länder vom
Angesicht der Erde tilgen wird und so
weiter wenn es das nicht gelingt in den
Griff zu kriegen und sagt innerhalb von
zehn Jahren müssen wir das umkehren weil
sonst Ernteausfälle Überflutungen
Umweltflüchtlinge Chaos und so weiter
ein Zeitfenster von 10 Jahren das klingt
wenn du das hörst nach einem Bericht aus
dem Sommer 2019 22
schätze mal wann der Artikel erschienen
ist ja ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
das schon den 90ern war richtig juni 89
und die düstere Vorhersage betrifft das
Jahr 2000 und natürlich mitnichten das
Jahr 2030 ja aber weißt du ein Punkt
darfst du nicht vergessen also das was
wir jetzt anrichten ökologisch ne unsere
jetzige CO2-Bilanz die rechtssicher
nicht im nächsten Jahr und auch nicht
aus den zehn Jahren sondern die
rechtliche Verlaufe der nächsten
Jahrzehnte
deswegen muss die Aussage nicht so
völliger Käse sein also vieles von dem
was wir jetzt anrichten wird erst nach
einer längeren Zeit überhaupt auf der
Erde spürbar völlig richtig ne deswegen
ist es vielleicht nicht ganz okay aber
man sollte einfach eins lernen daraus ne
habe ich auch selber mal gelernt muss
ich mal meine eigenen Fehler korrigieren
ich habe also früher auch gerne mal so
so Zeiträume mal meinen Vorträgen so ins
Auge gefasst ne wann könnte mutmaßlich
das selbstfahrende Auto sich durchsetzen
oder ähnliche Dinge und ich habe gelernt
ja vermeide Zeitangaben und zwar du
kannst ja mit allem Recht haben was so
sagst aber wenn die Zeitangabe auch nur
um ein Jahr nicht stimmt hast du
Kokolores geredet das Merkwürdige ist ja
immer auf diesen auf diesen
Veranstaltungen wo es um die Zukunft
geht so digitalkonferenzen und so werden
ja immer Prophezeiungen gemacht für in
20 Jahren in 20 Jahren ist schlauer als
in 10 Jahren erinnert sich keiner mehr
an die
Profession erinnerst du dich im
Wahlkampf
die die großartige Geschichte
ja auch in 50 Jahren muss heute
20-jähriger sichtbar sein dass eine gute
Rente kriegt das schlimmste was
passieren kann ist dass man das in
seinen Grabstein ein meist sind aber er
kann auch darauf zählen dass sich daran
irgendwann außer uns beiden kein Mensch
mehr erinnert richtig richtig aber ich
will nur sagen was das am anderen Ende
anrichtet und das ist etwas was ich
zunehmend wahrnehme und deswegen finde
ich müssen auf die Sprache viel mehr
aufpassen deswegen habe ich ein Problem
damit wenn geredet wird von der
Klimakatastrophe auf die wir zu rasen
und so weiter ja gerade die die die die
junge Leute die ich sehr respektiere der
letzten Generation die benutzen solche
Wörter und reden von Milliarden von
Menschen die sterben werden und so
weiter es gibt mittlerweile gute
Untersuchungen und Studien speziell von
britischen Psychologen die die
Auswirkungen solcher reden auf Kinder
untersucht haben und die sagen dass
Kinder mittlerweile Albträume haben rund
um das Thema ja es gibt unendlich viele
Blogs und Videos von Jugendlichen die
davon ausgehen die glauben das weißt Du
Kinder nehmen alles eins zu eins dass
wir bis 2030 Aussterben täuscht dich
nicht ein Zehnjähriger weißt du der wenn
es gibt Bilder von von einem
extinction Rebellion Mitgründer der so
eine endzeitrede gehalten hat steht auf
einem Tisch und redet auf zehnjährige
ein in einem Klassenraum in England das
geht nicht ich finde das geht einfach
nicht das kann man nicht machen und da
muss man wirklich aufpassen es gibt ein
Begriff dafür mittlerweile Öko Angst
also die chronische Angst vor dem
Untergang der Welt Angststörungen das
ist das ist die Konsequenz daraus
geworden damit meine ich nicht dass man
die Dinge nicht klar benennen sollte
aber ich finde wir müssen mit der
Sprache aufpassen und ich ich sage dir
wenn du junge Eltern fragst Menschen die
kleine Kinder haben oder so Jugendliche
die die werden dir das bestätigen und
ich merke das ja auch das war ja auch
damals mein Thema bei Carla Rochel von
der letzten Generation die in der
Sendung war
dass die die wirkt ja auf mich wie
jemand der absolut kann Vertrauen mehr
keine Zuversicht mehr in die Zukunft hat
und dass das darf nicht sein womit wir
wieder bei Davos
und in den Autos
eine wichtige Funktion also die Tatsache
du musst ja nicht vor Schulkindern
predigen aber die Tatsache dass es
Menschen gibt die das was die
Wissenschaft hier prognostiziert oder
viele Wissenschaftler ein bisschen
vorsichtiger formulieren die das ernst
nehmen und diese diese Zahlen dann auch
für sich verwahre Münster nehmen und
dafür sind sie auch eigentlich gemacht
spielen natürlich eine wichtige Rolle um
überhaupt
ein Umdenken auszulösen absolut also wer
den Teufel nicht an die Wand malt und
wer auch nicht hinreichend Angst vor den
Konsequenzen macht dann passiert ist
dass man immer so zum Kölner wird und
sagt hätten einmal Idiot die junge und
sagen auch eine Tempolimit kann ich und
SUVs kann man auch noch in 20 Jahren
fahren und dann haben wir ja keine Panik
und so also gegen diese Gemütsruhe ja
die ja nun definitiv in den Untergang
führt und dann ist es egal ob das in 10
20 oder 50 Jahren ist sich hin zu
stellen und zu sagen ja pass mal auf
nimmt doch mal die Zahlen ernst und
überlegt doch mal was dabei rauskommt
ist doch ein absolut wichtiges Korrektiv
die werden ja nie regieren aber sie
werden die Funktion eines Kollektivs
erfüllen können wenn wir sie ernst genug
nehmen noch mal bin ich total bei dir ne
du verstehst mich schon auch genau
richtig mir geht's nur um die Sprache
und mir geht's um die Botschaften die
wir in dieser medial so vernetzten Welt
setzen und ich finde da muss auch jemand
wie der UN-Generalsekretär mal ein
bisschen aufpassen was man so sagte dass
die Welt in einem Zustand ist wie Autos
bei einer Massenkarambolage und solche
Sachen dass das finde ich irgendwie
finde ich irgendwie ich finde das nicht
zulässig ich finde das sicherlich
Gedanken machen jetzt mal ungeachtet der
Frage ob das jetzt eins zu eins ganz
ganz genauso stimmt also das ist
tatsächlich nicht nur fünf vor zwölf
sondern im Grunde genommen fünf nach
zwölf ja weil wir die Folgen und die
ganzen Langzeitfolgen unseres
Wirtschaftens in den letzten Jahrzehnten
die sich zum Teil erst später erst
auswirken noch gar nicht jetzt und so
das eigentlich alles verloren ist mein
gesetz den Fall das stimmt
was ja nicht unwahrscheinlich ist wie
würdest du jetzt wenn du die Möglichkeit
dazu hättest pädagogisch strategisch mit
diesem Wissen umgehen
ich glaube einfach weißt du es gibt
darauf nicht die absolute und perfekte
Antwort Richard ich glaube einfach nur
dass gerade wir als Menschen aus den
Medien die entweder selber reden oder
anderen ein Forum geben dass wir eine
Verantwortung haben wir alle und dieser
Verantwortung müssen wir irgendwie
nachkommen weil wir immer mitdenken
müssen dass da eben auch andere zuhören
die vielleicht die Jünger sind du wir
haben beide schon häufig darüber
gesprochen über diesen Enthusiasmus ja
und diesen wahnsinnigen Idealismus
junger Menschen der auch so toll ist
aber der natürlich dann genau dazu
führen kann dass du irgendwann das
Gefühl hast du schaust nur noch in den
Abgrund und ich mit tun die manchmal ein
bisschen leid wenn ich das so sehe weißt
du die hatten jetzt diese corona-phase
hinter sich vielen hat diese diese
Pandemie komplett das Studium
geschreddert ja alles was wirklich dann
zu diesem Studium noch dazu gehört und
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen dass wir
nicht immer weiter in diese in diese in
diese diese Apokalypse rein reden ohne
dabei Dinge verharmlosen das ist
natürlich völlig richtig und wenn wir
sagen diese alte Kontinent noch mal
zurückkommen sozusagen zu Davos und zu
unserem zu unserem Thema hat ein Problem
würdest du sagen
Europa ist das Museum von dem Fergus
entspricht wirds zu sagen die
Globalisierung ist vorbei wird zu sagen
es ist jetzt wirklich Zeitenwende und
Morgen wachen wir in der neuen Welt auf
also drei verschiedene Sätze also diese
blöden Satz da morgen in einer neuen
Welt aufgewacht hat hat mir alles
sowieso noch nie gefallen ja also das
passiert vielleicht viel zufrieden oder
so dass sie in anderen Welt aufmachen
aber also das finde ich Unsinn weil das
wirkt so als wäre über Nacht irgendwie
ein großer Zauber gekommen und hätte die
Welt verändert und das trifft einfach
auf die Situation nicht zu
die andere Sache
Museum würde ich sagen Ja zur Hälfte ja
also das ist schon sehr viel museales an
Europa ja und das wird auch irgendwie
rein quantitativ Musikal also irgendwann
wurde mal von Europa aus die ganze Welt
verändert also durch die industrielle
Revolution die Wirtschaftskraft
Kolonialisierung Imperialismus und so
weiter alles von Europa ausgegangen auch
die USA sind ja mal von Europa
ausgegangen und heute geht von Europa im
Vergleich dazu deutlich weniger aus das
gilt im Guten wie im Bösen ja das heißt
also die Bedeutung Europas schrumpft in
der Welt ja ist leben die meisten
Menschen auf der Welt leben in Asien
mehr als die Hälfte der Weltbevölkerung
in ganz Europa leben weit weniger
Menschen als in China weit weit weniger
Menschen wir sind aus chinesischer Sicht
irgendwie sowas wie eine wie eine
festasiatische Halbinsel
wir haben also gar nicht diese Bedeutung
vom Reich der Mitte ausgesehen und diese
Bedeutung wird im direkten Vergleich zu
den anderen kleiner das steht glaube ich
fest damit steht ja noch nicht fest dass
das Leben bei uns ungemütlicher wird
oder wie alle in Armut fallen aber das
unsere Rolle in der Welt unbedeutender
wird ich glaube das trifft zu und
darüber kann man sich einerseits ärgern
weil man dann weniger gestalten kann und
andererseits kann man sich freuen dass
die ja diejenigen die so lange in der
Welt zu kurz gekommen sind dass deren
Stunde dann auch irgendwann mal schlägt
ja also dass sie Aufsteiger mal dran
sind und nicht nur die etablierten der
dritte Satz davon dass das Ende der
Globalisierung ist halte ich für totale
Zahlen Quatsch
also ein Ende der Globalisierung geht
nicht wenn man sich die Abhängigkeiten
mit der internationalen Weltwirtschaft
voneinander anguckt dann braucht man
nicht einmal entfernt die Fantasie zu
haben ja das hier eine deglobalisierung
stattfinden könnte das wäre das Ende von
allem und zwar überall und deswegen wird
das auch nicht passieren ich halte das
für Rhetorik ich halte das für Rhetorik
um den Einlass ein oder andere Ziel
durchzusetzen aber es geht gar nicht
Deutschland verkauft von 10 Autos 4 in
China die Chinesen sind mittlerweile in
was den Export von Autos anbelangt haben
sie Deutschland überholt also das für
viele noch unvorstellbar die Chinesen
produzieren mehr Autos die Sie im
Ausland verkaufen als die deutschen
Autos die Autos
er ist wichtig
das was wir besonders gut konnten dass
wir also mit dem Verbrennungsmotor mit
die besten Autos der Welt gebaut haben
das wird im 21 Jahrhundert dauerhaft
überhaupt keine Rolle mehr spielen das
Auto wird durch etwas anderes ersetzt
was E-Auto ist nicht nur ein Auto mit
einem anderen Antrieb das ist etwas was
im Prinzip jeder bauen kann und was
irgendwann immer billiger werden wird ja
aber wir bauen schon schöne Autos die
Frage wird irgendwann vielleicht nicht
mehr so wichtig sein doch doch nö nö das
glaube ich nicht das glaube ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht das wird nie ein Produkt
weißt du das ist so wenige Pferdezucht
ja wo du sagst ja aber wir haben die
besten Rennpferde ja das kann man machen
damit kann man natürlich Reitsport kann
man damit machen und solche Scherzchen
aber als normales Fortbewegungsmittel
werden die Pferde trotzdem ersetzt und
so wird das dem Verbrennungsmotor
ergehen ohne unseren ganz ganz tollen
E-Autos wenn dann irgendwann in den
Städten der Zukunft die Autos alle ganz
klein werden ja und wenn der Verkehr was
ganz anderes wird dann nützen diese
Autos nicht mehr richtig ja
und das ist das eine aber was die Autos
angeht das ist natürlich schon
interessant gab es ja kürzlich erst eine
große interessante Studie dazu Europa
wird Auto Importe
das ist natürlich also eigentlich haben
wir die Karren immer gebaut und und in
alle Welt verschifft jetzt werden wir
plötzlich Auto ja weil wir keine kleinen
und billigen E-Autos herstellen
weil wir das was die Städte in der
Zukunft brauchen weil wir das nicht
produzieren sondern weil wir nichts
anderes gemacht haben als mit der
E-Mobilität ja diese Status
diversifizierte Produktpalette des
fetischisierten Individualverkehrs
wieder zu wiederholen statt etwas
anderes zu machen
das ist für die Zwischenzeit sinnvoll
gewesen das war die Idee von Tesla die
Idee von Tesla waren E-Auto muss gar
nicht klein und simpel sein sondern kann
eine super statuskarosse sein
wie lange es Tesla noch gibt ich glaube
nicht so ewig nee bist du aber drauf ich
weiß es doch nicht weiter wichtig ist
doch für jemand wie Elon Musk völlig
egal wie lange es Tesla gibt wenn die
Kuh keine Milch mehr gibt dann wird sie
geschlachtet es geht doch nicht mehr
darum Unternehmen aufzubauen die VW die
100 Jahre halten sollen oder wie die
Daimler oder wie Opel oder wie fort das
ist doch im heutigen Kapitalismus nicht
mehr wichtig man besetzt eine Nische
sagst du übergangsnische ja vom von der
Status Karosse zur eMobilität indem man
eben im mobilitätsstatus Chaos macht die
braucht man nicht mehr irgendwann in 10
oder 20 Jahren und dann macht man halt
was anderes dann investiert man sein
Geld in andere Projekte
also ich würde den Befund würde ich
nicht teilen und dergleichen über
Jahrzehnte hinweg noch Tesla geben wird
Teslas ehrlich gesagt nicht meine
Hauptsorge aber meine mein Thema ist
das Thema deutsche
Industriearbeitsplätze das ist das Thema
und wenn du wenn du darüber redest finde
ich dann will ich hoffen dass die großen
deutschen Konzerne noch möglichst lange
in unserer Mitte sind warum warum warum
weil andere Dinge hier also die Menschen
können ja einen anderen Bereichen
arbeiten das hat doch schon immer z.B
was ist denn mit all den Leuten also
jetzt gehen wir mal so ins Jahr 1910
oder 1915 und sagen was soll denn aus
den ganzen Leuten werden die vom
pferdeverkehr Leben weißt du wie viel
hunderttausende das gewesen sind das
sind ja nicht nur die Kutscher gewesen
das sind die Riemer Meister gewesen die
Kutschen hergestellt haben die Wagner
das sind die die Sattlermeister gewesen
das sind die Hufschmiede gewesen ja das
sind die die Leute die da Strophe die
Pferde bereitet haben das Heu
organisiert die Bauern die dafür
gearbeitet haben und und und und und und
und und was ist denn aus all den Leuten
geworden als die Pferdefuhrwerke in
kürzester Zeit aus den Städten
verschwunden und die elektrischen
Straßenbahnen kamen und das Auto kam
heute beschäftigt die Automobilindustrie
zusammen
deutschsprachigen Raum annähern 2
Millionen Menschen noch
also ich meine solche
industriestrukturumbrüche die hat es
doch immer in der Geschichte gegeben ja
und trotzdem sage ich dir also du weißt
nicht dass ein einer der Gründe warum
ist Deutschland so lange gut ging war
genau die Tatsache dass wir unsere
Wertschöpfung aus diesen
Industriearbeitsplätzen hatten der
Facharbeiter der rundum Stuttgart
Wolfsburg und so weiter sein Geld
verdient und ich sage dir auch die
Innovationskraft kommt daher ne also ich
habe jetzt zahlen für dich Richard weil
ich mich mit dem Thema
öfter beschäftigt habe ungefähr im Kopf
2 19 2 18 nagelmäßig fest aber
Patentanmeldungen du siehst ganz genau
wo die Innovation die deutsche
Ingenieurskunst ist wenn Du Dir mal die
Patentanmeldungen in den einzelnen
Bundesländern anguckst ganz oben
Baden-Württemberg warum ja Porsche
Daimler Bosch die sitzen da alle ja ganz
viele ganz viele Mittelständler
nur es sind ja nicht die großen Konzerne
die gar nicht so innovativ sind sondern
das ist ja das ist ja wirklich also die
die Brutstätte der Kreativität in
Deutschland ist der Mittelstand ich weiß
und Baden-Württemberg da natürlich ganz
was voll aber nur mal ganz kurz die Zahl
ungefähr 15.000 Patentanmeldungen in dem
Jahr Bayern BMW und andere 14.000 enorm
viel NRW
viele Autozulieferer und so weiter
Niedersachsen auch interessant VW 4000
jetzt sag mal Bremen ja oder Berlin
könnte ich mir auch vorstellen 150
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern 89
es ist vollkommen klar sozusagen
mit Leibeigenen
ja da ist also anders als in
Baden-Württemberg ist kein bürgerlicher
Mittelstand entstanden
deswegen sitzen die Tüftler in
Baden-Württemberg das hat was mit
Religion zu tun das hat was mit der Art
und Weise der der Produktion zu tun ja
also das ist ein ein Land gewesen von
unselbstständigen Bauern
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Brandenburg und
so weiter da sitzen natürlich nicht die
Ideen schmieden schmieden haben nie da
gesessen
ja also die die Landwirtschaft meldet
relativ selten patenter ja das ist
richtig aber ich will nur sagen das hat
dann solche Dinge haben dann auch
unmittelbar und da bist du dann beim
nächsten Thema Auswirkungen zum Beispiel
auf die Demografie ne also wenn wir ein
Land mit Mecklenburg-Vorpommern anguckst
wunderschönes Land bin da gerne ist aber
ein leeres Land wenn du dadurch fährst
gerade so schön da dran ja ich liebe
Brandenburg und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
als also landschaftlich geht mir das
Herz auf da sich ja du alter Romantiker
wirklich frag mal die Leute irgendwie
die da wohnen und keine Jobs haben das
ist doch nicht schlimm wenn da weniger
Menschen leben ich habe ja immer gesagt
in Brandenburg hatten wir Deutschlands
Antwort auf diese energeti daraus ein
Nationalparkhaus Brandenburg mache alles
also
du willst
Adler ich bin mit dir
na wieso die müssen doch nicht alle
gleichmäßig über Deutschland verteilt
sein nein aber es gibt Menschen das ist
deren Heimat und wenn ein ein Land ein
Staat trieben aber wenn du jetzt wenn du
jetzt arbeitest oder eine Lodge
betreibst dann gibt es endlich meine
wirtschaftsperspektive für Brandenburg
da kannst du doch wunderbar wie in
Afrika wunderbare Lodges machen da
kommen die amerikanischen Touristen und
gucken sich die Palio europäische
Tierwelt an die was die Paleo
europäische Tierwelt du kannst auch
wieder Auerochsen rückzüchten unter
aussetzen und so weiter dass sie ja
quasi wieder so ein Ursprungs Wildnis
hast alles das was wir ausgerottet haben
bei uns in Europa
laufen lassen ja du du als du als wie
sind Lodge Besitzer in Brandenburg
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem für so
ein Land ne ich meine gibt ja viele
Länder Demographie schaust dir an wenn
Industriearbeitsplätze weg sind die die
brachen in den USA die brachen auch in
anderen osteuropäischen Ländern Aderlass
den zum Beispiel was was Bevölkerung
angeht Bulgarien Rumänien und so weiter
was die hinter sich haben das ist
Wahnsinn haben wir schon mal drüber
gesprochen das führt natürlich nicht
dazu dass ein Land dann irgendwann Post
beein prosperierendes Landes ja das ist
läuft das junge Leute dort wieder
hinziehen dass Menschen sich zutrauen
etwas aufzubauen all das meine ich und
das meine ich auch mit diesen mit diesen
industrie-arbeitsplätzen zum Beispiel
und es ist doch wichtig dass es die gibt
und du siehst doch jetzt schon dass die
Leute wenn du sagst die Leute können ja
dann wegziehen den Jobs hinterher nein
der deutsche Facharbeiter der klassische
deutsche Facharbeit das mittlerweile
ähnlich wie du ein passend zum
Mentalität des Landes ja auch in einem
Alter wo er ein Haus gebaut hat eine
Familie gegründet hat und wo es eben
nicht mehr trivial ist ob du einfach mal
so eben kurz von Stuttgart nach keine
Ahnung wo siehst das ist eben nicht mehr
egal
deswegen müssen wir doch zusehen dass
dieses Land weiterläuft und weiter
funktioniert und deswegen sind diese
Industriearbeitsplätze so zentral und so
wichtig nach meiner Auffassung ja also
ich bin kein Illusionist ne also die
Industriearbeitsplätze haben uns reich
gemacht eben aber wir müssen auf der
anderen Seite immer sehen wir können
keine musikalen Bestandsaufnahmen machen
das heißt wir können also
Schlüsselindustrien nicht über
Jahrzehnte hinweg subventionieren damit
die Arbeitsplätze nicht verloren gehen
also das ist diese diese merkwürdige
Form von sozialistische Arbeitsplatz
Politik die wir ja auch gemacht haben im
Bergbau es wäre ja so viel besser
gewesen statt über 20 30 Jahre lang den
Bergbau weiter zu subventionieren mit
Milliarden Beträgen da hätte man für das
gleiche Geld geben der da ein Bergbau
arbeitet in der stattliche Pension fürs
Leben sein könnte
also diese Art dass wir uns von etwas
nicht trennen können und dass wir zu
lange versuchen tote Gäule durchs Ziel
zu reiten dafür gibt es sehr viele
abschreckende Beispiele die mit sehr
viel Lobbyismus durchgesetzt worden sind
und diesen Fehler dürfen wir nicht noch
mal machen also wir dürfen nicht
versuchen die Autoindustrie über
Jahrzehnte künstlich zu pimpern
weil das natürlich die Zeit ist die wir
dafür verschlafen neue Dinge zu
entwickeln und da sind wir da haben wir
einfach Tempo verloren ne also woran es
bei uns vor allen Dingen krank ist ja
nicht dass wir nicht genug kreative
Köpfe haben die haben ja noch genauso
wie früher wir haben auch hervorragende
Universitäten wir haben sehr gut
ausgebildete Leute aber es fehlt bei uns
am entrepreneurship das heißt also der
Weg vom können und vom Wissen zur
Firmengründung das ist das was bei uns
ausgesprochen schlecht funktioniert und
das hat übrigens in Baden-Württemberg
mal im 19 Jahrhundert unglaublich gut
funktioniert
das heißt also das war ja nicht nur dass
das die Tüftler waren die da auf der
Schwäbischen Alb saß warum zum Beispiel
dadurch dass die Kredite gekriegt haben
neu gegründete raiffeisensystem zum
Beispiel ne als kommt ja alles Sachen
die aus Baden-Württemberg kommen dass
man dass man klein und kleinst
Unternehmern ja quasi sowas heute würde
man ja sagen so in naturkredite aller
Yunus gibt oder so dass man also diese
Entwicklung auf fördert und dass man da
hilft und so aber jetzt mal von der
schwäbischen Provinz ja zurück nach
Davos also was interessant daran ist
wenn wir jetzt über Davos reden ist ja
immer die Frage wer sich da trifft ja
und da trifft sich ja der Homo da wo sie
Kuss ne also der da wo es Menschen
genannt worden ne und ähm es gibt ja so
in der
Paleo Anthropologie den chromanierung
Menschen ja oder die sowas Mensch und
genauso gibt es in Davos Menschen
eine bestimmte Auswahl von Menschen und
das was der der Homo da wo sie groß ja
eigentlich will ist dass die alten
Spielregeln unter neuen Vorzeichen
weitergehen das ist der Sinn des World
Economic Forum in Davos man kann auch
sagen wir sind es dass man sich mal auf
Augenhöhe trifft aber ehrlich gesagt es
gibt genug Privatflugzeuge um sich auch
so irgendwo zum Dinner in Dubai zu
treffen sondern eigentlich geht das ja
darum so ein bisschen abzustimmen was
man machen muss damit die alte
Weltordnung erhalten bleibt unter sich
verändernden Vorzeichen das ist so
eigentlich jedes Jahr das Thema unter
dem Davos stattfindet und dann ist es
immer so eine Mischung aus dem
beschwören des alten und so dass man die
Change Mentalität hat und dass man so
die Zukunft besser verstehen und da darf
man eben nicht vergessen dass eben da wo
es eben auch eine museale halt
europäische Versammlung ist
die Welt nicht
so vertreten dass man sagen kann da wird
jetzt normalitätisch geguckt ja also die
Anzahl der Afrikaner in Davos ist
deutlich kleiner als die Anzahl der
Europäer in diesem Jahr ja nicht in
diesem Jahr sind interessanterweise sehr
sehr viele Afrikaner Sicherheit deutlich
weniger Afrikaner da als Europäer aber
ich will es nur sagen die Bedeutung des
Kontinenz ist richtig aber aber
eigentlich war es ja so ein 70 so
gegründet dass die damals Mächtigen der
Welt die gleichen die sich beim G7 oder
G8-Gipfel treffen dass die eigentlich
diejenigen sind die so die
Weltwirtschaft unter sich ausmachen und
ich bin gespannt ob es gelingt von Davos
aus oder dem Homo da wo sie Kuss dass er
in der Lage ist sich auf die multipolare
Weltordnung einzustellen
das heißt also das Forum mit Davos
müsste ja eigentlich ein Jahr in Davos
stattfinden und dann ein Jahr in
irgendeiner chinesischen Stadt und ein
Jahr in einer afrikanischen Stadt
meinetwegen so sollten wir vielleicht
mal anfangen
um einfach zu zeigen also auch
symbolisch zu zeigen wie die Welt sich
diesbezüglich verändert
ich glaube das wäre zum Beispiel ein
wichtiges Zeichen und das wäre auch ein
wichtiges Zeichen dass das dass die
Menschen in Davos mehr und mehr lernen
die Welt aus verschiedenen Perspektiven
zu sehen wie wir das ganz am Anfang am
Beispiel von frankieren und China
besprochen haben und ich glaube um der
multipolaren Weltordnung mit vielen
anderen starken Mächten mit einem
zunehmend bedeuteren afrikanischen
Kontinent
mit einem etwas bedeutenderen
südamerikanischen Kontinent vielleicht
auswärmen zu Wünschen mit einem ohnehin
immer stärkeren Asien das eine solche
multipolare Weltordnung dort gedacht
würde und davon ist glaube ich Davos
noch weit entfernt ich glaube man ist
immer noch so beides weißt du auf der
einen Seite möchte man die alten
europäischen oder westlichen Privilegien
verteidigen ja und es skeptisch
gegenüber den anderen und auf der
anderen Seite weiß man dass man so
dauerhaft nicht überleben kann und
dieser unausgegorene zwischen Zustand
der beschreibt eigentlich relativ gut in
welchem Zustand unsere wirtschaftlichen
und politischen Eliten sind
ja ich habe auch ein Problem sozusagen
damit das trotz vieler schöner Worte nie
die große Aktion daraus folgt ja ich
habe ein Problem damit dass dort Leute
sich zusammentreffen und und groß und
intensiv über den Zustand des Weltklimas
sprechen und dann fallen dann solche
Sätze wie mit der
massenkaramolage und den Autos und so
weiter weiter und der Highway to
klimahel und so weiter und gleichzeitig
kommt ein Großteil dann mit Privatjets
von denen Greenpeace gerade darauf
hingewiesen 53 Prozent mehr als die
Hälfte dieser Flüge sind kurzflüge unter
750 Kilometer Flughafen in Davos für
Privatjets sperren ich weiß gar nicht
warum
das einfach da musst du Klaus schwarz
fahren so das ist der Gründer ne
deutscher Ökonomen mittlerweile auch 85
Jahre alt und deswegen hast du so recht
wenn du sagst irgendwie der trifft sich
sozusagen die alte Elite die aber ganz
offensichtlich sehr gerne in ihren
Privilegien festhält um dem Rest der
Welt aber zu erklären wie er gefälligst
zu leben hat und damit habe ich ein
Problem ja also Petition nächstes Jahr
nicht mehr mit dem Flugzeug nach Davos
pass auf Nein vergessen noch mal zum
Abschluss Richard der Historiker aus
Schottland ja total guten Satz gesagt
über Deutschland weil ich zitiere mal
vor dem Ukraine Krieg habe ihr in
Deutschland die wahnhaftes Leben geführt
und geglaubt dass Mutti euch dauerhafte
Stabilität verschafft seit
Kriegsausbruch ist klar dass das
deutsche Modell von russischem Gas von
Exporten nach China und von Amerika
Sicherheitsgarantien abhängig ist
Merkels Erbe ist dass Deutschland wieder
der Michel ist der im 19 Jahrhundert
schon mal war das ist hart mit dem
Michel ist ja klassischerweise immer
Verschlafenheit
zusammengebracht worden aber wenn der
Michel jetzt aufwacht was sollte er denn
gänzlich anderes machen ja ich glaube
muss er muss er muss echt
wirklich mal aufwachen und auf die Beine
kommen er muss vor allen Dingen die
Schulen in Ordnung bringen er muss die
Bildung in Ordnung bringen er muss sich
die Frage gefallen lassen warum bei uns
ein Mensch von zehn die einwandern
jemand ist der ein arbeitsmigrant ist
während den Kanada zum Beispiel einer
von drei einer ist der für ein ganz
bestimmten Job ins Land kommt wenn du
sagen da funktionieren so viele Dinge
nicht wir bringen die Leute die kommen
und es sind nun mal die die sie sind
aber die bringen wir nicht in Arbeit und
wir stellen jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal
zu dem bildungsthema sagen wenn Staaten
Alter ne und das ist nämlich unwicht wir
haben ja schon über das gefühlte Alter
der deutschen die Deutschen sind etwas
jünger als er Staat ja also der Ende der
40er Jahre gegründet wurden aber da so
da langsam nähert sich sozusagen das
gefühlte Durchschnittsalter und wie dem
Alter der Bundesrepublik an und wenn
starken Eltern dann verkrusten und
erstarren sie genau das haben andere
Staaten uns schon sehr böse vorgemacht
Großbritannien z.B ja auf Frankreich ist
in bestimmten Erstarrungen vor
christungen uns weit voraus und was
bedeutet das das bedeutet dass sie keine
aufstiegsgesellschaft mehr sind ja das
also der der Weg dass man sich über
Bildung befreit und wenn man nur fleißig
und hat Nick ist sowas die Generation
unserer Eltern anbelangte ja wo aus den
Kindern von Handwerkern Ingenieure
wurden und und und
das ist bei uns fast verloren gegangen
das haben wir nicht mehr das heißt die
soziale Dynamik friert ein parallel dazu
nimmt die Bürokratie zu liegt ja also
ein absolut unterschätztes Thema man
Fluch der gerne drauf aber es völlig
unterschätztes Thema ist die Bürokratie
unser Bildungssystem krankt nicht daran
dass wir nicht gelegentlich auch mal
einen tatkräftigen Politiker haben der
da gerne was ändern möchte sind nicht
viele aber es gibt ja aber selbst wenn
wir jetzt jemand Kultusminister würde
der alles verändern will und dann
richtig die Schulen für die Zukunft
flott machen und Schulen machen in denen
das Wichtigste ist dass man selbst
Management beherrscht dass man kreativ
ist neugierig ist mit Menschen gut
umgehen kann und so diese ganzen
wichtigen Dinge
der würde so was von ausgebremst auf aus
allen Verwaltungsebenen
das heißt die Schulen sind bei uns nicht
deswegen so wie sie sind weil das ein
politischer Wille wäre dass sie so sein
sollen sondern weil jeder der dieses
dicke Brett bohren will mit dem Bohrer
darin stecken bleibt und das einzige
Wort wo die Intelligenz des Menschen nie
ausgereicht hat ja wirklich große
Leistungen auf diesem Gebiet zu
verbringen ist Bürokratie abzubauen weil
jeder Versuch Komplexität zu reduzieren
und das weiß man sehr gut aus der
komplexitätsforschung Komplexität erhöht
muss als erstes neues Gremium der
Kommissionen schaffen
unterwegs war also jetzt im Ernst da
liegt das größte Problem wie ersticken
und bei einem der Verkrustung und dieses
Problem haben aufsteigende Staaten für
den wir ja mal gehört ne Deutschland 50
oder 60er Jahren war ja mein Tiger Staat
sozusagen
nicht wirklich
Ursprung und jetzt als als Vorleger
gelandet ist wie sind Felge landet sie
sind
klar wunderbar oder auch nicht Richard
ich danke dir das war ein interessanter
Austausch freue mich sehr für unsere
Folge über China ja und ich freue mich
einfach mit dir irgendwann mal
tatsächlich auch mal durch Brandenburg
spazieren zu gehen mit einem Fernglas in
der Hand weil wenn du den Zauber dieser
großartigen Landschaft diese Stille
diese Ruhe und mit ganz viel Glück einen
Blick ohne Windrad ja wenn das also
nicht keine keine Gesicht was schwer ist
ja genau aber wenn du tatsächlich
einfach mal so einen Tag erlebst an dem
fast 20 Greifvogelarten an einem
einzigen Ort zusammenkommen was du sonst
nur in Israel bei der Wanderung hast
dann wirst du irgendwo die Mystik
Brandenburgs spüren und dann wirst du
verstehen dass das was ich vorhin
zwischen Scherz Ironie und tieferer
Bedeutung über Brandenburg gesagt hat
nicht völlig abstrus ist
ich
bin dabei aber das tatsächlich einer der
Gründe warum ich gerade die die die
ostdeutschen Länder so gerne mag ich ich
finde auch Sachsen-Anhalt völlig
unterschätzt natürlich wunderschön kein
Bundesland hat so viel Wald ja also wir
müssen in einer Größe ja und ist auch so
diese romantische diese diese mehr
anderen kleinen Flüsse und so weiter ich
finde das so so schön wo du ramelo sagt
jedes Mal wir sollen doch jetzt einfach
mal anfangen in Erfurt zu produzieren
warum eigentlich nicht ja ich denke da
noch mal drauf vielleicht sollten wir ja
ich habe ja ein plädoy jeder dafür
gehalten ne die die Welt und das
Weltgeschehen aus verschiedenen
Perspektiven zu sehen also multipolar
und vielleicht sollten wir mal mit einem
multipolaren Blick auf Deutschland
anfangen ja gut gute guter Punkt ein
schönes Schlusswort Richard danke sehr
ja bis dann tschüss
[Musik]
keine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
potstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]